tips on how you can be a better intersex
ally
when it comes to inclusive language
oftentimes people tend to use phrases
like people with penises or people with
vaginas rather than saying male and
female are men and women while this can
absolutely be inclusive for trans people
unfortunately it's not always the most
inclusive language for intersex people
my advice is to use language that
focuses on function and not just form
that means focusing on the actual
function that you're talking about such
as people who can get pregnant people
who can get other people pregnant people
who are at risk of testicular cancer and
so on and so forth
[Laughter]
that's your real suggestion
that that's really that's that's uh
at some point i'm in the good old days
bro
uh ladies gentlemen people in between
people that are more prone to get any
testicular uh
uh cancer people that are prone to have
breast cancer people are not prone to
have a breast cancer people are at risk
at 23 they have prostate cancer
everybody uh that have or have not a
spleen everybody that their pancreas is
working 30
everybody jesus [ __ ] christ you know
what this feels like wow
you know this feels like
good day colored people i mean people
who are more at risk for getting high
blood pressure and diabetes
but that that includes fat people too
uh
people who are more at risk for uh
[Laughter]
one because there's one word it's just
so much easier i'd rather just say
something super racist and just come out
with a [ __ ] full sentence
no lie don't lie listen okay
[Laughter]
um
hypothetical and i need my black people
in the chat to answer
okay hypothetical
this is how you know what's going to be
[ __ ] up i can't even get the words out
if you had to choose between referred as
two choices
[Music]
people people
people who suffer from high blood
pressure diabetes in in food deserts
or
which one are you choosing because i'm
not gonna lie to you it is me i mean i
don't like neither but
that's one word
you're saying that you you lazy
so people that get that are more prone
to suffer from high blood pressure uh
diabetes and laziness
lazy
[Music]
my god
i'm sorry this is just so ridiculous i i
had to counter with some ridiculousness
okay we're just having laughs
be easy someone that comes to be like
how the type of [ __ ] to let a white
girl call him nick
oh that's what's good they're definitely
gonna say that and let me be clear i
would never
never unless it's part of race play
this video is brought to you by
manscape manscape has everything you
need to keep it clean and want to talk
about keeping it clean i'm talking about
under under under the you know under the
sea little mermaid keeping your
seashells by the seashore if you will
first and foremost you need to trim
trim your booty to trim your booty
[Music]
we have the lawnmower 4.0 you could use
it underwater there's a guard for you
not to check your balls you know because
you don't want to chip them you know
what i mean you want them nice and clean
lawnmower submersible there's two
products that are wonderful too the crop
preserver and the tonic for your crop
well the preserver is basically a
deodorant you can't always just put
water and soap under your armpits right
sometimes you need deodorant well your
under under your tinga ling ling is the
same you can use the preserver just as a
deodorant and if ever you're on the go
you can use a tonic to have a little
freshen up snip snip let it dry and
you're good to go and right now you can
get 20 off plus international free
shipping plus two gifts by manscape if
you go today on manscape.com and you use
promo code preach that's
p-r-e-a-c-h you already know what it is
this is much more inclusive because
there are intersex people who are born
with the vagina but don't have a uterus
or ovaries or an ability to menstruate
this is because some people that are
born of the penis don't have testes so
it's much more inclusive to say what you
actually mean than it is to use language
that works around that you know you know
what's the point of words anymore what's
the point of words this isn't my wife
this happens to be the first girl i met
before i hung out those are great dating
markets so now we're married
i'm saying like why is that wife because
it's not inclusive of people who don't
want to be married understand or some
people who got married too young and
actually want to get a divorce so this
term is much more inclusive like what
are we talking about
really what's the use
i want you guys to peep something it's
always the people who talk about
inclusivity and empathy who try to
co-opt language and words and try to
make everyone curtailed to what they
want to do
right they have all these like corny
lingo that is just like so
nonsensical but they also have a course
of people who will never call them on it
because those people want their work
work points or they don't want to seem
like bad people and i know because we're
in the arts and we've seen it bro people
change the way they talk people change
like
oh you can't use this term anymore it's
like you guys are pushing it and it
doesn't even make any sense or as i say
losers
there you go i can't take this [ __ ]
no i can't take it it's not a thing is
it a thing
it's not a thing it's nothing that that
she's not it's not a thing she proposed
it out there but it's not that's not a
thing let me ask you something 15 years
ago there's a bunch of things that
weren't a thing
and today aren't they things bro bro bro
i'm trying to say that and maybe it's
not going to be true all right that's
just me being like i'm i'm i'm swimming
in denial right now the night is not
just a river in africa i'm swimming in
it it's not a thing it's not a thing i'm
like i'm like uh
dorothy there you go i'm dorothy and
toto and
there's no place like home there's no
place like home this ain't a thing that
saying a thing clicking my shoes
bruh
i think you only have that stance
because
you live on the top layer and as a
result you don't recognize the ways in
which you oppress everybody on the
bottom two layers and as a result you
just go through life thinking like you
don't have to change your language you
have to change your use of words and
that's why you're part of the oppression
but the people on the bottom layer the
other layers the ones who are suffering
to the fact that you won't change your
[ __ ] words listen i don't personally
believe in violence but i hope you
[ __ ] die
try to avoid using intersex people as a
gotcha or a talking point unfortunately
it's very common to see intersex people
being used as a way to win an argument
against transphobes specifically when
they're arguing that there are only two
genders it's common to see people say
well if there are only two genders then
what about intersex people you know what
i actually agree with her
first off these people are such a small
percentage of the population like it's
barely worth mentioning and secondly
okay exactly i think one of the most
important thing is that
their experience is completely different
due to a variety of reasons maybe it's a
matter of genitals maybe it's a matter
of like in their entire life we can't
make
decisions based off of that because it's
such a it's like making every decision
with the thought of like what if the
person has no likes
um you know what i'm saying it's okay to
create new things to make
things accessible but i wouldn't make
every car
for people who have no legs you
understand what i'm saying yeah that
doesn't make sense no
you can create technology for them to
make
cars more accessible yeah i agree but i
wouldn't be like every car should be uh
thoughtful people with no arms looks
like [ __ ] then what about the [ __ ]
who got arms who want to use that
utility like this is so pointless yeah
right so that's why
i agree with her in that regard
as a way of stumping their opponent into
agreeing that there are more than two
genders unfortunately using intersex
people as a gotcha in this situation is
very harmful and reductive it's using
intersex people our bodies and our
communities to win an argument but not
giving us any resources support or
recognition
so the next time you're in an argument
against a transphobe try not to bring up
intersex people just to win an argument
especially when you don't provide other
support and resources to intersex people
in general we're gonna watch all our
videos bro i cannot no no
no why not no i'm good she got some good
stuff
do you want to hear more about the ways
in which you're living on the top layer
no look at your face you're just looking
for something hot and agree just no i'm
looking at something and i'm and i'm
debating whether i want to open it you
really want to yeah if there's one thing
that i'm looking at that i'm like i
don't know if i want to open it
but
hey little [ __ ] let me whisper in here
show you a video you might like to watch
does pcos or polycystic ovarian syndrome
fall under the intersex umbrella pcos is
considered a hormonal disorder that
affects people who are assigned female
at birth symptoms of pcos often include
things like an absentee irregular period
thick body and facial hair or either
skin and acne and other such
characteristics this is because pcos
typically includes hyperandrogenism or
higher levels of testosterone and other
androgens though it's been a point of
contention within the intersex community
many intersex activists are starting to
accept the fact that people with things
like pcos and gynecomastia do
technically have experiences that fall
under the intersex umbrella a friend of
mine and fellow intersex activist hansen
doll said something about pcos that's
not what this means
but okay
it doesn't necessarily
you know what it's all good i won't do
this to you no i won't do this this is
not this is not what that means
no
that's not what i mean yeah you know
because there's people but people with
probably kisses uh ovaries syndrome um
they have more facial hair and they have
more details so they fall under that not
necessarily
no it does that's not what it means you
can have oh my god
no that's not what no no
two different things about honestly i
didn't understand anything that was
happening on screen so i just wanted to
play it for you probably kiss to ovary
syndrome and then you're no no no i
refuse yeah
god damn hopefully you guys uh enjoyed
today's video uh this is one of those
ones that we don't do very often but i
wanted to check it out oh my god uh is
that a shortcut let me take it for no
goddamn reason between this subject and
that subject let's go
they like their umbrellas
i don't know if it's raining over there
but they like their umbrellas okay
rihanna calm down
lgbtqia222 plus
lgbtq that's a lot less light under one
umbrella yeah yeah that's a big ass um
brother
ella ella
everybody getting wet nobody gets
if we be honest everybody getting wet
nobody get no protection nobody's
getting dry